One of the things we've been talking about
in a sort of hypothetical sense since the
riots in Washington, DC on January 6th is
if instead of being a mostly white male conservative
crowd there, storming the Capitol, fighting
with police, pushing police with barriers,
hitting police with fire extinguishers and
on and on and on, if it had been a Black Lives
Matter protest, if the political orientation
had been different or the racial makeup of
the people there had been different, would
it have been allowed to go on for as long
as it did?
Would it have been handled in the same way?
And I think intuitively, most of us who understand
the way things have gone down in the United
States for the last many years can only come
to the conclusion that, no, it would not have
been the same if the protests last week had
been different groups of people in terms of
their makeup or politically oriented in a
different way.
We don't just have to intuit our sense of
that because we actually have a study about
this.
And Barack Obama shared this on his Twitter
account recently.
And the study was lead was done by Acleda
ACL said it's a data reporting project and
it looked initially.
They used to look at armed conflicts in African
countries and then they started looking at
the United States.
And in the United States, we've had so many
protests, riots of different kinds, that there's
plenty of fodder and data to look at.
And what Occlude found is that law enforcement
is much more likely to try to shut down left
wing protests than they are right wing protests
when law and.
It uses force to shut them down.
They are much more likely to use force in
the left wing protests than in the right wing
protest by a 51 percent to 34 percent margin,
more than half the time when they decide to
shut down a left wing protest.
They use force only about a third of the time
when they decide to shut down a right wing
protest, they use force.
And there are a number of different things
to consider here.
You might say, well, maybe the left wing protests
are more violent and thus it makes sense that
police are more likely to try to shut them
down or to use force.
That is not what the data actually shows.
The data does not show that left wing protests
are more violent than right wing protests.
Another consideration would be where are the
left wing versus the right wing protests taking
place?
In other words, political orientation.
Of the protest aside, are the left wing protests
happening in places whose police departments,
for other reasons, are more likely to prevent
them from going on too long?
Where is the right wing?
Protests are happening in places whose police
departments are more lax in allowing them
to go on.
That also does not appear to be the case.
And so this is a really a concern.
This is not a trivial thing.
And and where I believe much of the investigation
needs to be is in the political orientation,
not just of the police officers, but of the
police departments.
And this also includes mayors.
We know that law enforcement is a relatively
conservative group.
Law enforcement in total supported Trump in
twenty twenty at a much greater level than
the average population.
So, of course, there are liberal police departments
and police departments with liberal police
chiefs or that work under liberal mayors.
There's no doubt about that.
But overall, the makeup of the officers tends
to be far more right wing than the average
population.
This also applies to the military, although
we did see in twenty twenty that the military
was more supportive of Joe Biden than they've
been of of most past Democratic candidates,
at least going back a number of elections.
So certainly we have to consider whether the
political orientation of the officers plays
a role.
And also if you have right wing officers,
but a more centrist or center left police
chief and mayor, how does that affect the
handling of protesters?
What we know is that when we talk about the
right to protest, if the left wing protests
aren't more violent and we know that they
are not, but yet police are more like, oh,
and the left wing protesters are not more
likely to be armed and they are not, then
we have to say, well, why is it that the left
wing protests are more likely to be shot down?
And is that it?
Is that a restriction of speech?
And we've seen right wingers either misunderstand
or pretend not to understand when the First
Amendment is a factor.
You know, Twitter suspending Trump is not
a First Amendment issue.
It has nothing to do with the First Amendment.
We hear all the time my First Amendment rights,
my First Amendment rights trumps First Amendment
rights when it has nothing to do with the
First Amendment.
When you see a political discrepancy in which
protests are shut down along the lines of
the political orientation or motivations of
the protest by police, under the guidance
of police chiefs, city councils, mayors, ET,
you really actually have to start asking questions
about whether the government is suppressing
speech and suppressing it along political
lines.
So none of this is is a catch.
All that explains every circumstance, but
it's a very good data analysis.
538 has a write up about it.
Again, the organization that did the analysis
is Acleda a lead and will link to the article
about it in the description on the YouTube
clip for this story.
Take a look at it.
Let me know what you think.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman,
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.